And I'm excited. We have two Waldenstroms talks in one session for such a rare disease. That's
really exciting. So I'm going to be presenting data. This is actually from my colleague,
Jorge Castillo at our center. This is his trial that we've been enrolling patients on. So I'll
give you an update on this. And so as we just heard, there are many therapies available for
Waldenstroms. But the issue is with a lot of our therapies are indefinite or patients don't achieve
really deep responses. And so we're trying to improve on that with this trial. So we used
Pertabrutinib and Venetoclax. Those are both known to be safe and effective in Waldenstroms.
The downside to those agents, so Pertabrutinib, as I just mentioned, is one of those indefinite
therapies. And Venetoclax, the original trial, the treatment was for two years. But then when
treatment was stopped, about half a year later, it was gone. And so we're trying to improve on
half of patients relapse by six months. So many of us give that indefinitely or have that high
risk of relapse pretty quickly. So although those are both available and they work well,
we're trying to improve on that. And we know that the combination of BTK inhibitors and BCL2
inhibitors generally are safe in other diseases. This trial was kind of a follow-up to our prior
trial that was Ibrutinib and Venetoclax, which was stopped due to high cardiac toxicity.
With multiple patients who had ventricular arrhythmias. So we're very cautious and
careful with this study using this combination. And luckily, knock on wood somewhere, we have
not seen any issues with that in Waldenstroms so far with Pertabrutinib.
So again, this is Foriacus Dios trial investigator initiated multi-center phase two trial. This is
in patients who were previously treated for Waldenstroms. They had to have had
a BT or they had to have had one line of therapy before. And what we were looking for in this trial
was the VGPR and CR rate. As mentioned before, many of our therapies have higher overall response
rates, but the depth of response is quite limited. With Venetoclax alone, only about 20% of patients
achieve a VGPR or CR. With the BTK inhibitors, it's about 20 to 30% of patients. So we designed
the trial with this statistical plan, as you can see, with an alternative hypothesis of greater
than or equal to 35% VGPR or CR. And the null hypothesis, when we made this plan, would be
rejected if 12 or more patients achieved that. And you'll see in this data I'm about to present
that even with only partial enrollment of the trial at the time of this data collection,
we had met that endpoint. So the key inclusion criteria, adult patients with Waldenstroms
who needed therapy and that had one treatment before. Initially, we allowed patients that were
mid-88 negative.
In the trial, we had two patients who were treated, and unfortunately, both of them relapsed
pretty quickly. So then we modified the trial to only include mid-88 positive patients after that
point. And you can see the treatment schedule below. So her tabrutinib is started on day one
and given as a single agent for the first month. And during month two, Venetoclax is ramped up
on a weekly schedule of 100, 200, and then 400 milligrams, with glucomycin, which is a
single agent for the first month. And then, as I mentioned, we've had close TLS monitoring, and we
haven't had any significant TLS.
So the baseline characteristics, as expected with Waldenstroms, a median age of 69, mostly males.
Prior therapies in this trial was a median of one. About half of the patients had had a prior
covalent BTKI exposure. And of those patients that were exposed, most of them were resistant to
covalent BTK inhibition.
The T4 rate was pretty close, slightly higher than the typical rate at 44%, and 19% of patients had
a TP53 mutation.
So here you can see the responses with a median follow-up of 11 months. 55% of patients had
achieved a VGPR or CR, so we're seeing pretty deep responses. This is even, you know, patients
that were not completing the two years of treatment yet, and we were already seeing these deep
responses. We have now completed enrollment in this trial, and I'll say we're continuing to see
similar outcomes now with all of the patients enrolled in the trial.
We can see that there's a difference in response to therapy, though, as you see here. So these are
the patients that achieved a VGPR or CR. That's the burgundy color, and then the blue is patients
who achieved less than a VGPR. So based on prior BTK inhibitor exposure, you can see that there's
less than a VGPR, and we can see those who had had a previous BTK inhibitor are less likely to achieve
a deep response. Some of these are not statistically significant because of small numbers at the time
of this analysis, but I wonder if they will ultimately be statistically significant when we
look at all of the patients enrolled. We also saw a difference for those who had a CXCR4 mutation,
less likely to achieve a VGPR, and the same thing with those patients who had a TP53 mutation.
So there are similar findings in terms of looking at time to VGPR. So you can see overall for the
whole population, the median time to VGPR was 5.8 months, but there is certainly a difference in the
curves for all three of the next charts that you can see there when looking at BTKI exposed,
CXCR4 mutated, and TP53 mutated, with a difference in the time to achieving that VGPR
for each of those three different populations.
Did very much clinically benefit from this therapy, though. As you can see, a significant
drop in the IgM when patients were treated. Hemoglobin improved nicely, and we also saw a big
reduction in the amount of disease in the bone marrow. So that differs from what we see with just
a BTK inhibitor alone. So we were getting cell death and eradication of most of the disease in
many cases. The progression-free survival at 12 months is 94%. You can see the safety profile here.
We did see some cytopenias, including mostly neutropenia, which responded to growth factor in
most cases, although some patients did need dose reduction. And from an infection perspective,
URIs were the most common and typically grade 2 or lower, and patients overall seemed to have
tolerated this quite well. So in general, with the 15 patients at the time of this data collection
of the VGPR-CR, the study met its endpoint. Although we do see prior exposure to BTK inhibitors
and the presence of a CX04 or TP53 mutation affect the time to achieving a VGPR and the
ability to achieve a VGPR better. And I think an important thing we'll have to follow up on this is
how long do patients maintain their response after coming off of treatment? Thank you very much.